I think you're weirdly you're like
ambiguous essentially and yeah racially
and yeah so I'm just waiting for it to
be my time man yeah
yeah right now because like even though
you kiss that dude on Barstool but I
think even a gay guy would look at that
and go
wait what was he and by the way I didn't
I think he kissed me he did kiss you
yeah yeah how did that play out yeah
well I don't remember I was in there and
then he walked in and then I think he
gave me he came in and like hugged me
and I was like if you're gonna [__]
kiss me go in
I think I might have said that was your
first time kissing a dude no
no
what
no dude
I went to an all-boy Catholic High
School
okay
that was my yeah dude that was you know
that was my first time you know kissing
a a guy who's younger than me oh okay
you know dude okay shout out Father Bill
yeah yeah yeah you know I kiss men bro
yeah
and gives a little boy yeah
it's 49 years of life I've never kissed
a boy but I kissed a [__] this
[__] 25 year old twerp yeah [__] is
he think he is yeah I'm kissing [__]
Vietnam war vets
you you were rated the best kisser and
you're all Catholic boys high school
dude these goddamn lips yeah you think
the priests had like their own little
personal category for that uh I'm sure
yeah I'm sure yeah yeah oh yeah oh yeah
well you know what I [__] uh I listen
I do what I'm told look we just met
but
this Flyer's crazy it's crazy
yeah we gotta fix this it doesn't work
you have such a track record you have
such a decorated career
you're more than this yeah I think what
did he do my guy put my face on Ken's
body yeah dude right this to promote the
theater at Madison Square Garden we're
not talking about an improv we're
talking about the theater and MSG this
does and this is this is what I come out
with ad for MSG that's what I call
right
this is crazy this is what I came out
with this is like the Flyers you did in
your first six months of Comedy right
and I was like what do you guys think of
this yeah
war or or or here's the other here's the
here's the here's the other side of it
or do we just show the fans that I never
change no matter what venues I'm doing
this is the same [__] you'll always get
or is that it no because I think okay
you know took a swing this look at this
one Sleepless in Seattle this one's okay
I like this one okay good yeah there's
like there's like design yeah it's
focused this is good yeah but I still
think you're better than this what about
the other one go up a little bit here's
another theater image what about the up
one more one more what about this one
Taxi Driver this is MSG but it doesn't
say man like yeah like none of this says
Madison Square Garden this just seems
like you floating photoshopping yourself
into your favorite movies
yeah yeah so in this way you do kind of
come across like a bit like you know
like neurodivergent or something where
you're like this is my favorite movie
and this is Mia's yeah I'm just saying
when you have dedicated fans that are
paying monthly to be referred to as a
muffin butt right you gotta show them
like you love them too and like give
them things like stand behind where
they're like no Chris is my guy look
he's doing MSG but then you give him
yeah this Barbie [__] and they're like I
don't wanna guys calling me muffin butt
he's got these Ken I mean I can't even I
can't even publicly love this guy I
don't want to show my family this yeah
yeah well this is why people aren't
buying tickets to Kansas City yeah
they don't even dude they don't even
know you're going there
[Laughter]
this tells me that you want to build the
bomb there I need a young 25 year old
kid who's I don't know what race they
are I don't know what sexual preference
they are I don't know where they're from
I need someone I need I need a 25 year
old Noel Miller yeah or honestly you
know with the best video editing I've
seen in the last five years is Isis so
maybe I'll have a little bit maybe I
need that people don't like seriously
you know I I love bringing that up
because there's a
uh the the younger people don't realize
how the production value Isis was
putting up it's [__] up you know it's
[__] up we're not talking about you
know we're not talking about the actions
we all know the actions are [__] up
yeah but they they did put out they had
some really good editors editors man
yeah not condoning the activity Isis not
but for just talking specific things
great editing on Isis
it's the truth yeah is this good for
Kansas City to sell tickets I think
there's a part of the clip I think this
is part of Kansas City that's like
yeah all right yeah all right we do it
yeah that's it you ready for this you
want to be in the building Kansas City
because if it doesn't sell out I'm gonna
kill myself on stage as the closer so
you're going to want to get your phones
out
yeah
no I think it all depends what you want
you got Isis hype dude they're gonna
show up they're going to be like dude
that's something we can cut together
finally I know the Taliban is back in
Afghanistan yeah totally baby yeah you
saw how they they all don't want to do
the um the office work now they don't
want to do that after they took over the
city they realized like running the city
had office work and they're like yeah
the clerical [__] and they're like oh
[__] this bro yeah oh yeah fed up with
office culture ready to quiet quit yeah
this might be a meme is this Saturday I
don't think so dude
it's time is this guy available
memes yeah yeah the guy working yeah now
that would be Progressive as [__]
Chrissy D hires former Talib uh designer
yeah I hired the Taliban to make my
[__] memes yeah
that's how dope I am
yeah
all right yeah now let's see going back
to that whole like half baked idea and
it's out there on the internet forever
right that that one's there which one
hiring the Taliban all right this is out
there yeah but it's comedy you know I
mean people who [__] don't get comedy
I wanna I wanna be very very clear I'm
not like get away from me all right no
not you oh people who hate comedy I'm
like I don't care they're different
people no look dude I I hear you on like
because I do think it's it's also
reasonable at a point to be honest of
like this is me like you don't want to
have to pretend
but
I also don't think it hurts to you know
just get a new perspective on how how
you present what you're doing the truth
is you gotta the people who don't want
to adapt die yeah always yeah don't
compromise your integrity but if you got
to adapt you adapt yeah but you can't
you know you can't be somebody you don't
want to be that's when you get in
trouble but you've got adapter done I
think that's all it is man and you've
done it many times in your career I feel
like everyone in entertainment has to
adapt at some point so I think you're
just you know if the pod's not doing
what it's doing and you're feeling a bit
mixed feelings maybe that's all it is
maybe it's just another time it's just a
presentation issue yeah all right
look at us
[__] yeah do you have more podcasts to
do today or am I the only one you just
it's just you man I like that I'm just
focused on you one and done yeah you
don't burn yourself out we usually do
two hours but
um you have a heart out or whatever so I
know
so stupid you got some [__] to do or
something two hours but it's two hours
because you want to because that's for
the algorithm and no it's because we
want to we uh okay you know for the
first hour that's for the public you
know we do the ads and then the second
hour is the bonus and that's where
that's where you say the spicy stuff
yeah that's where the boys kiss and oh
hell yeah they glaze each other I wish I
didn't have a hard out because I've got
a hard on yeah yeah yeah now really it's
just in the bonus we just watch like
bears killing each other and we laugh
that's [__] great yeah yeah what time
is it do I do I actually really have to
yeah you do have a heart out
oh [__] so guys it's 11 26 Pacific time
yeah so uh we guys we have to um end the
show now sorry Chris has somewhere to be
yeah so sorry about that Chrissy D has
somewhere to be dude um armpit sweat
yeah I noticed it I wasn't going to call
it out it's insane my armpits wet yeah
it's like it's insane people like you
should get a shot you should plug up
your uh no what no I'm just if God wants
my [__] pits to leak then they're
gonna leak that's crazy yeah dude you
can put silicone in your yeah dude I'm
not I'm not I'm not a plastic surgery
guy whatever people want to do but I'm
like just [__] don't alter it unless
you have to get surgery because you're
about to die yeah then you do it but
other than that I'm like stop I'm gonna
regret it when they figure out dicks you
changing your mind what do you mean like
when they figure out how to make them
gigantic up on command
um no dude my dick is so small I'd
rather just like it for me it's like
just make it smaller but still
functional okay you know what I mean
like I don't like that I like that I
don't like I don't need I don't want
anything big you know I'd like I like um
and maybe I'd say with my dick
I'm circumcised it's you know four maybe
inches not too many warts Yeah couple I
grew up you know guys our age you know
even in the 30s you gotta have a little
HPV yeah if you don't have it you're
lying or you weren't out there [__]
and having fun I wasn't out there
[__] like that so no you don't have
HPV I'm clean daddy prove it
um I
yeah you're a doctor you could yeah
everybody's got that one in where I'm
from let's get a little warts um but
yeah I think I would just I would want
to just make my dick look happier
sometimes my dick looks a little sad oh
but I wouldn't like to make it look
happy he's gonna give a little facelift
yeah maybe give a smile just make the
pee hole a nice little smile yeah yeah
yeah and take some of the wrinkles out
yeah yeah just make it feel good yeah
that's it make it less purple
Botox just make it smooth a smooth four
give it a smile give it a little tan
yeah you know it's a little too purple
right now it looks like Lou Ferrigno
yeah it looks a little beat up